we're going to begin with the new
efforts to help families that are hit by
america's shortage of baby formula it's
a very big club as you know while the
country's largest supplier abbott
imports millions of cans to make up for
the shutdown of its michigan plant
president biden has taken the rare step
of invoking the defense production act
to boost domestic supplies nicole
killian is on capitol hill where the fda
commissioner is testifying later today
on overcoming these shortages a lot of
very angry and concerned parents nicole
good morning to you yeah that's right
good morning to you gail and in his
prepared remarks fda commissioner dr
robert califf says that he is acutely
concerned about the availability and
safety of baby formula but that may not
be enough to satisfy lawmakers who want
to know how we got to this point
i know parents all across the country
are worried about finding enough infant
formula to feed their babies president
biden says he's directing his
administration to do everything possible
to address the national baby formula
shortage he will invoke the defense
production act to ensure manufacturers
have the necessary ingredients to make
safe infant formula the emergency action
allows the president to direct companies
to prioritize orders for the federal
government which has only been used
about a dozen times in the last two
decades mostly during the pandemic
the president is also launching
operation fly formula to import more
product from overseas to speed up
delivery we know where the product is
and we know we do not have enough the
bill is passed house lawmakers approved
two bills wednesday night one would
provide 28 million dollars to the food
and drug administration to prevent
future formula shortages this bill just
continues the democrats strategy of
throwing money at the same bureaucrats
who caused the crisis the other loosens
restrictions for families in the women
infants and children nutrition program i
want to say to the mom struggling that
we hear you connecticut's johanna hayes
received wic benefits as a teenage mom
and sponsored the measure i know what it
means to run out of milk in the middle
of the month but many of these families
they had their wic benefits but couldn't
even
use them at the store
because the options that were available
to them were off the shelves
about half of the formula purchased
nationwide is through the wic program
which is why having more options could
be critical for these families both of
these bills now head to the senate as
for the fda commissioner he will face
congress again next week along with
executives from some of the major
formula manufacturers nate
to the parents of infants just hold on
formula is coming soon nicole thank you